i think i would feel comfortable
counting an octopus as intelligent but
not the pig well i think the raven it
has to be
oh man
get me
[Music]
hey crazies welcome to another
installment of wife reacts this is my
wife awkward m hello today we're gonna
be talking about the fermi paradox
all right so as usual let's start with
uh what do you what do you know what do
you know about the fermi paradox
aliens
aliens it's aliens right
something about
um
there's so many
there's so much universe why
statistically
there should be aliens why haven't we
seen them
yes right
so the fermi paradox started in
1950ish at los alamos national lab there
were these four guys sitting at a table
for physicists
naturally yes
so we've got enrico fermi who
technically i think it's pronounced fear
me but it's gonna be uh it's an uphill
battle for me you'll try your best yes
and then there's emil
konapinsky edward teller and herbert
york they're all having this casual
lunch at los alamos okay
and then out of nowhere fermi just
blurts out don't you wonder where they
all are
if these other three guys weren't his
like friends and co-workers they'd have
no idea what he was talking about but
they were able to basically infer that
he was talking about aliens let's be
honest we all have that friend am i
right yeah
and then no one really thought anything
of it after that in fact fermi ended up
dying four years later
at the time of his death it was just
this casual conversation he had with
some friends and then turns out that
those friends would continue to discuss
this
philosophical debate and it would
eventually become known as the fermi
paradox
this actual conversation was sort of
like a physics urban legend
for a while no one knew if it was
actually true well sure why why would it
have been recorded or written down or
right you know just a bunch of friends
having a casual conversation
it wasn't actually substantiated until
like 19 mid 1980s some other guy at los
alamos was like you know this supposedly
happened here i wonder if this is
actually true and so went through the
trouble of like calling up the other
guys at the lunch and at that point
they're like super old you know but they
remember the conversation and they they
they told him when it happened and
everything and so like it did actually
happen and it ended up being real a real
story interesting
also be careful what you say kids might
come back up 35 years later right
but with that in mind the paradox sort
of hinges on two assumptions okay always
always with the assumptions yes in
physics well you have to make some you
know you can't go off of nothing right
sure the two assumptions are the cow is
round
yeah we're already spherical cows and
and and cubic chickens and it's nothing
that crazy
the two assumptions for the fermi
paradox are
that there are many intelligent species
in the universe okay and two
we should have been able to detect them
by now okay
it's a paradox because when we look out
into the universe we don't hear anything
we don't see any evidence of their
existence right it's like any paradox we
need a solution
also just like any paradox it comes down
to those assumptions
one of them must be wrong right either
there aren't that many intelligent
species
or
we
shouldn't expect ourselves to be able to
detect them okay which i'm sure that we
will
get into right
what i want to do today is i want to
focus on the first assumption
why do we think that why do we think
that there are many intelligent species
in the universe okay
during fermi's time that was
more of just wishful thinking i guess no
one had really like sat down and done
any like actual calculations
but it sounds like they have since been
done yes around 1961
there was this guy by the name of frank
drake okay ah i see where this is going
yes
so i have a nice little visual aid for
you oh thank you
it's just a bunch of factors multiplied
together i see that ultimately what this
does is it gives us the number of
communicating intelligent species in the
galaxy so right off the bat in our
galaxy right not in the universe right
okay the first three numbers
the r the f p and the n e we actually
know pretty well okay if we're analyzing
that first assumption in the fermi
paradox that there are many intelligent
species then it's gonna come down to the
these last four numbers okay
specifically f l f i and l okay the
second to last the fc is about
communication and so that's about
detectability and that's more related to
the second assumption okay and so the
other three f l f i and l
are where we have a little wiggle room
where we don't really have a lot of data
we basically have one data point earth
and so this is where we get to make very
subjective judgments right right about
how this equation is going to turn out i
just i just feel the need to get it off
my chest
is that i feel like something that this
does not take into account is that we
are assuming that all life is gonna be
like us
and honestly i mean you have to because
what you don't know you don't know right
but i just feel like it needs to be said
that there could be life out there it's
just so different from us that we don't
know it or understand it or see it right
and and i i feel like as we go forward
with this you're gonna have a lot of
things to say being a biologist okay
when it comes to these three factors
the solution to the fermi paradox would
mean that one of these numbers is
extremely small much smaller than we're
actually anticipating okay much smaller
than our heart would like i guess
as we can see here fl is the fraction of
those habitable planets that do end up
having life on them f i is how many of
those planets with life on them evolve
intelligent life
l is the length of time that species can
communicate with us called the lifetime
factor okay
in years all you can really say about
that l is that it's the the length of
time that that species communicates or
at least is detectable by human means
okay but it's so we're talking about the
group and not an individual correct
question okay
not the entire you know
start to finish for the species because
they're not necessarily communicating
for that whole time like you were saying
right
these three factors
fall under one big umbrella something we
call the great filter okay as life
evolves and as an intelligent species
grows
you know biologically or technologically
there will be some kind of filter that
stops them from going any farther or
stops most species from going any
farther at least so we call it the great
filter there is some big insurmountable
obstacle that is keeping the number of
species low okay
starting with the first factor here fl
the fraction of those habitable worlds
that have that actually have life on
them not intelligent life just life any
life bacterial is fine okay
early earth history was
sort of defined by something we call the
heavy bombardment right the whole the
whole solar system was full of a bunch
of rocks it was tumultuous yeah it was a
bad time it was the surface of the earth
was basically like lava yeah yeah but we
know sort of when that heavy bombardment
ended
and
at that time
there was already life existing on earth
right and so somehow life was existing
at least near the end of the heavy
bombardment period
which is wild as soon as it was possible
yes i was like bing i'm here
i personally
put a 1 or 100 in for fl if life is
possible it exists on that world i think
the real question is is what happened
here
typical or not and it's another one of
those things that
we don't know
right you know and so i understand why
you know
you can make that assumption
because in the absence of information go
with what you know
right but i do feel like it it's worth
noting
we could be the exception right and not
the rule even though here life began the
moment it could that could be unusual
that's exactly what i'm saying right it
could turn out that or that earth like
worlds with life are extremely rare
right
and we're making sort of we're making a
statistical judgment on one data point
we shouldn't be
not that we shouldn't be because again
it's not like we have more data or that
we are able to collect more data and we
have chosen not to
there's there's just not the data out
there right it's not available and so
you have to make
some assumptions like we said earlier
and you either have to assume
it is common and what we did is normal
or it's not common and i feel like you
are telling me that both sides have been
taken into account with different
hypotheses while i personally would put
a one in for this factor other people
wouldn't and given the data set that we
have that is also a valid answer exactly
where i would personally put a great
filter is in the next factor okay the
this is the fraction of life-bearing
planets that would evolve into an
intelligent species in fact that
particular like sub-category of the
great filters
is considered the rare earth hypothesis
because that's tough man we know that
the moment life was possible life began
but we're talking like super simple
bacterial life what we call what
prokaryotes prokaryotes no atom no no
atomic nucleus i would hope there's
atomic nucleus no cell nucleus
just a container of stuff single
cellular yes single cellular life
also on earth though
that was basically all life was for a
very long time for very and in a
for so long that i don't think our
brains appropriately appreciate how long
it was speaking of that actually now you
bring that up i'm gonna try to talk
about these numbers instead of billions
of years
let's try to talk about them in terms of
something i did in a previous video
where it was galactic years okay and so
that's the the amount of time it takes
the sun to go around the center of the
galaxy it's about 230 million earth
years is one galactic year
and this should help make the numbers
more comprehensible okay earth formed 20
galactic years ago so earth has only
gone around the galaxy 20 times i mean
it's quite a hike though so right it is
it's a very long hike sorry almost legal
drinking age right
life began
somewhere between like 16 and a half and
17 and a half galactic years ago so it
took a few galactic years for that heavy
bombardment period to end it was it was
a while
eukaryotic life that's life with a cell
nucleus
that didn't evolve for another like
eight galactic years which is just so
long during those those like eight
galactic years in there we're talking
billions of years during those eight
galactic years life on earth was just
prokaryotic life it was just a bunch of
bacteria it was very successful they
just hung out and they were doing their
thing they were just fine and then a
couple of them decided that they were
going to like work together and then
boom mm-hmm eukaryotic life and then
uh if i'm understanding the scriptures
all of them decided that they were going
to work together nothing like
anthropomorphizing your bacteria
yeah they just happen to
stumble into this mutually beneficial
relationship i'll accept it okay thank
you for the correction
people think that things
do things on purpose yeah much more than
they do right we are way way a long way
from brains here right we're still
talking single cells uh how many
galactic years are there in between the
first eukaryotic cell and the first
multicellular organism
a lot a lot of galactic a lot of
galactic years the eukaryotic cell was
like two billion years ago right so
we're talking 8.7 galactic years ago
okay so something that i always struggle
with is talking about years ago and then
like years since right it was about
halfway okay eukaryotic cells were about
halfway okay and so it was eight
galactic years from the beginning and
eight galactic years ago ish okay which
is a long time yes very long to go from
single-celled eukaryotes to
multicellular organisms was another five
galactic years
so many once life began it took eight
galactic years
for eukaryotes to show up and then
another five for multi-cells
multicellular organisms
it took another five galactic years for
multiple cells to start working together
as one organism yeah
these transitions seem to be a lot
harder yes than just life beginning as
prokaryotes absolutely well because when
you become a multicellular organism it's
now it now means that each one of the
individual cells
that there are some of those that can no
longer survive on their own outside of
the organism right because there were
colonies a colony is just a group of
cells that like
they're better off living together than
living apart but if one of them gets
kicked out he's gonna make it right once
you become a multicellular organism you
can't do that anymore you all have to be
together or else yeah or you're dead
yeah uh and so it's a big step
all of the complexity that we see on
earth today all the animals and all the
plants and fungus and all that stuff all
of that happened in the last 800 million
years in the last 3.5 galactic years
right so the last three and a half times
the the sun has gone around the galaxy
it's been busy yeah and so huge growth
after that that was a very successful
transition now eventually intelligent
species evolved i think it's arrogant to
think we're the only ones you know there
were plenty of other closely related
species that were around on earth that i
would feel very comfortable saying are
intelligent such as i'm just not sure
what you're such as uh neanderthals okay
they may not have reached our
technological advancement
but they were certainly an intelligent
species i think the interesting question
is do we have to stick with the hominins
in order to talk about intelligent
species
you're talking like like an octopus like
an octopus yeah they were very early on
evolutionarily speaking when you're
looking at like animals you know what i
mean a totally independent evolution of
intelligence that's what i'm asking very
different intelligence than we have
right you need to be not too restrictive
of what you mean by intelligence okay so
if we were looking at a different planet
in a different solar system and we saw
something like an octopus or like a pig
right which are also intelligent yes
we would count that as intelligent life
i
or is it just up to the scientists
it's speaking it's it's subjective and
you know that always any of these values
come with biases right there's always
biases
i think i would feel comfortable
counting an octopus as intelligent but
not the pig well i think the raven it
has to be
oh man
get
me
i'm trying to think about what the
spirit of this equation is what does the
word intelligence mean in relation to
this equation and that's the question
i'm asking right and i think it means
that the species could develop into
something that is detectable it doesn't
mean they are detectable eventually but
it means they could
the species can develop into something
that is capable of communicating with us
and therefore becoming deductible is
that what you mean right well i mean
detectable
frank drake's original idea behind this
was that it was radio right that they
would eventually develop radio signals
that could travel out into space
we have to kind of decide like well are
any of these obstacles that earth has
run into in the past are those the great
filter and we're through it we're safe
now
we're the ones that made it are we the
first species the first species to
survive the great filter in the galaxy
in the galaxy
so far we've been assuming that the
great filter is in our past right that
is not necessarily the case there may be
in the future yeah there may be some
insurmountable obstacle that we
can't even
fathom that is in the future we can
fathom right or we're living it right
now looking at you climate change yeah
climate change is a possibility uh
nuclear war it's a possibility yeah i
feel like star trek has given us many
options over the right over the years
over the series there are a lot of a lot
of ways a species could just suddenly
end they weren't prepared for a change
or whatever so i think i'm leaning into
they could absolutely be out there and
the hurdles are just too big the the
detection hurdles and the signal hurdles
i'm i'm
i'm happy with there being 90 out there
or whatever right it's like that's the
point like even if you set some of these
values these ones that we have freedom
with
you say oh well there's this great
filter that's going to make those
numbers one of those numbers really
small
the number is still not small right in
the end right we're talking on the order
of a hundred species in the milky way
galaxy just our galaxy right in order to
get the final value the number of
species to be small like one per galaxy
or per universe
you would have to go really really small
on one of these numbers it's a it's it's
definitely a
possibility but it does not feel like
the most likely possibility going really
really really small with those numbers
right
while i say that like if there's a great
filter i think that it's eukaryotic
cells
i don't actually think the great filter
is the solution to the paradox okay i
think we shouldn't be so arrogant to
think we could detect them i do too
i think that's really the issue here
yeah
on that note i did take a poll in
various places i did the community tab
and twitter and facebook and stuff
47
of you think that the great filter is
the solution to the fermi paradox and
that that filter is ahead of us
sorry
dang
you guys are
rough
47 of voters think that we're not gonna
make it basically bummer and that's just
that's just sad that sucks
y'all are pretty depressing is the the
main takeaway there you're bringing us
down okay
i guess in the comments tell us what you
think the solution to the fermi paradox
is there has to be a solution
one of those assumptions has to be wrong
which one do you think it is thanks for
liking and sharing this video a special
thanks goes out to all my patreon
patrons and youtube members for all
their generous support and uh until next
time remember it's okay to be a little
crazy
two sunsets in a single day don't you
mean a single year nope i meant exactly
what i said on mercury the sun actually
dips below the horizon in a false sunset
only to come back up for a bit and then
go back down again in a true sunset
anyway thanks for watching